[Music]
welcome back to science Creek today is
it possible to go faster than light we
often hear that the expansion of the
universe accelerates some objects faster
than light itself indeed some objects
see the distance that separates them
increase faster than the speed of light
but this is due to the expansion of the
universe itself the underlying grid upon
which are placed all entities this grid
is in constant expansion which is why
the distance between objects constantly
grows larger this is not actually true
movement it does not enable us to send
information faster than light except for
the expansion of the universe is it
possible for an object to move faster
than light through space the theory of
special relativity enables us to grasp
the fact that the speed at which an
object moves in space modifies the flow
of that object's time the faster the
object moves relative to the observer
the more the object's own time slows
down in comparison to that same
observers time if this same moving
object carried a clock then the time
taken for the arms of that clock to go
full circle would be greater and the
time taken by those of an identical
clock which would lie at rest in the
object's environment so the quicker an
object moves in space the slower it
moves in time to quantify this situation
we can try to draw a very simple graph
which represents the passing of time in
relation to the speed of an object for
an object at rest with a speed of 0 time
passes at a hundred percent of its
normal rate in turn for an object
traveling at a hundred percent of the
speed of light time would simply stop or
in other words go by with a speed of
zero
naturally we might think that if time
can come to a stop when we reached the
speed of light it might be possible to
take it one step further and go back in
time if it were possible to travel even
faster than the speed of light the more
we would accelerate beyond the speed of
light
the quicker we would be going backwards
into the past with a flow of time that
would be negative this is an idea which
seems at first glance entirely plausible
and even very attractive however it
relies on a fundamental assumption which
should not be left unchallenged this is
the fact that we have extended and
connected both points by a straight line
indeed there exists a certain curve
which connects these two points and upon
which are placed all objects of the
universe any form of matter any object
can be found on this curve and as soon
as it begins to move at a certain speed
time relative to that object will
inevitably flow at a determined pace in
sorts time comes to slow down in the
same way for all objects given that they
have the same speed when we look to see
whether or not this curve is actually a
straight line we find out that an object
moving at 50% the speed of light sees
its own time go by not at 50% of normal
rate but at 87% of the normal rate of
the flow of time likewise an object
moving at 80 percent the speed of light
sees its own time go by at 60 percent
normal rate and an object moving at 25%
the speed of light sees almost no
difference as its own time goes by 97%
normal rates
[Music]
the curve which appears before our eyes
turns out to be not a straight line but
a quarter-circle and any matter
contained in the universe can be placed
somewhere along this quarter circle just
like our straight line this curve can be
extended until forming a full circle
left of the graph the negative speed
simply correspond to speeds obtained
while moving in the opposite direction
if moving towards the right gives a
positive speed of one mile per hour for
example then moving with a negative
speed of minus one mile per hour simply
equates to moving towards the left with
that same speed to start things off we
see that is neither possible to go
faster than the speed of light nor to go
beyond the rate of 100% the flow of the
observers time indeed even for a
hypothetical object which would be going
back in time that is with a flow of time
that would be negative it remains
strictly impossible to go beyond the
speed of lights because all objects are
confined to this circle the question
then is not to know if it is possible to
go beyond the speed of light but rather
to understand why such a thing is
impossible why our curve takes the shape
of a circle and what is so special about
the speed of light
let us begin by looking at the
particular shape of this curve a circle
one of the key properties of a circle is
that all the points which compose it are
situated at an equal distance to its
center for any object the only
meaningful measure is neither the speed
at which it moves nor the rate at which
its own time flows but rather the
distance from the center of the graph
this measure takes into account both the
object's movement in space and its
movement in time it is in sorts a
unification of the two speeds we combine
both the objects movement in space and
in time
this is speed in space-time whatever the
speed of an object whether it speeds up
or slows down its position then the
graph will change but it's distance that
the center will always stay the same
this measure is a fundamental constant
Universal it rules over all entities in
the universe it is this same measure we
call the speed of light it is important
to understand that the speed of light is
something fundamental its importance
does not come from the fact that it is
the speed at which light travels its
importance comes from the fact that in
space-time when we consider both space
and time it is the speed at which all
objects in the universe move with this
in mind we can get a better
understanding of the phenomenon at hand
objects cannot go beyond the speed of
light because they actually move without
precise speed under all circumstances
the only thing which can change is the
way in which an object's speed is
distributed over space and time if the
object is rather high up in the graph it
gives a lot of its speed to time and
very little to space its own time flows
with the rate that is very close to
normal but it moves very slowly in space
this is the sort of behavior exhibited
by objects in our everyday lives which
either at rest compared to us or moving
very slowly in comparison to the speed
of light
on the other hand if the object is more
towards the bottom right-hand corner of
the graph it gives more of its speed to
space than time the fastest objects in
the universe move very fast in space and
consequently very slowly in time they
actually evolve in time in slow motion
compared to us this is the case for
light in particular which gives all of
its speed to space leaving none to time
a light particle moves extremely fast
but its own time does not pass at all if
a light particle carried a hypothetical
clock with it the arms of that clock
would not even move an object which
speeds up does not actually gain speed
it will only convert its temporal speed
the one which enables it to move through
time into spatial speed which enables it
to move through space this is equally
true the other way around an object's
slowing down is one which converts a
part of its spatial speed into temporal
speed it slows down in space and
consequently speeds up in time on the
whole though its speed and space-time
has remained constant it is still moving
at the speed of light it is only the
distribution of that speed over space
and time which has changed to conclude
this representation in the form of a
graph has many advantages as it is very
visually appealing and enables us to
Intuit certain phenomena for example we
might wonder whether or not there exist
objects in the lower part of the graph
intuitively such objects would be going
back in time since their temporal speed
is negative following this reasoning we
might be able to postulate that there
exists a specific kind of particle in
the universe which would be situated in
this part of the diagram this type of
particle is what is commonly called
antimatter
antimatter particles have identical
properties to regular particles only
their electric charge is reversed they
are in essence the symmetrical
counterpart of ordinary particles the
part at the top of the graph is where
regular matter is while in the bottom
part it's mirror image is the world of
antimatter as for light particles also
known as photons these are themselves
their own symmetrical counterparts being
on the horizontal axis they are their
own antiparticles it is important to
remain cautious however since all this
representation is only based on the
model of special relativity which holds
only in an empty and perfectly flat
universe in reality our universe is not
flat it is filled with stars and planets
which distort in 4 dimensions the
geometry of space-time under these
conditions we must look to the theory of
general relativity in general relativity
gravity does not exist it is the
curvature of space-time which naturally
converts an object's temporal speed into
a spatial one if an apple which was
originally at rest falls from a tree
this is because it's evolution in time
has gradually converted into an
evolution in space in other words of
speed as a result of the curvature of
space-time which is due to the earth
if we observe from far out an object
situated next to a massive entity like
the earth then the graph associated with
that object will begin to distort itself
next to a black hole the circle becomes
so distorted that it becomes smaller and
smaller as the object comes closer to
the horizon when the object reaches the
event horizon the circle has become
entirely contracted this means that the
object has no margin left for movement
from our point of view it stays
motionless at rest with the surface of a
black hole when we observe them from far
out all objects which fall into a black
hole end up appearing stuck on its
surface but for the object itself
this phenomenon is only an illusion from
its point of view it is possible to go
through the horizon of the black hole
and gradually continue falling towards
the central singularity however for us
observing the situation from outside all
information contained by this object
slows down until it reaches a final stop
and remains fixed on the surface of the
black hole one of the most important
consequences of this phenomena is that
the entropy of a black hole meaning in a
sense its information and temperature is
entirely distributed along its surface
[Music]
[Music]
you